post something and I see like stop
stealing Theo's jokes like it's just I
don't I'd never have done that so
many of my jokes man it's crazy like the
show day actually yeah one time this guy
made his son a wooden shirt a wooden
shirt yeah he made his son a shirt out
of plywood for Christmas all these
shirts are 100% wood what a concept what
yeah he wanted a kid to wear it oh yeah
he did is it a stiff shirt or is did he
make it like little itty bitty tiny
pieces of plywood and weave it all
together oh n it was pretty stiff that
with Theo vau you guys both had a
similar idea he said on a yeah it was
like a wooden shirt then you guys had in
the show I remember when we came up with
the wooden stuff in the writer's room
and it was totally built on a different
idea that was about like a man whose
entire house was made of wood down to
the clothing and then it ended up we
ended up not going with that storyline
ended up doing one small really
inconsequential scene of my Series where
a guy was just selling wooden shirts
it's a pretty broad idea like the idea
of wooden clothing yeah I I don't know
I'm sure I don't know